this Kuroda virus seems to have shaken
up life as we know it inevitably it's
going to continue to spread but how far
and fast that's going to happen and what
we're going to do about it are still in
question
so could artificial intelligence play a
vital part in providing some answers and
maybe even improving the outcome AI had
an important role in the initial
understanding of this outbreak Canadian
specialists Blue Dot deals with global
epidemic intelligence and identified
very early on that something was amiss
through a combination of medical and
airline data we were one of the first
groups in the world that identified this
outbreak
this was back actually on New Year's Eve
day the morning of December 31st the
machine learning algorithms that we've
developed had picked up information in
Chinese of a pneumonia wasn't known to
be a corona virus of unknown cause
centered around this market in Wuhan
when it was presented to our team we
recognized that there were parallels to
the SARS outbreak 17 years earlier so we
knew immediately that there was some
historic parallels here and that this
outbreak really warranted our attention
and this is where the human scientists
were needed hey I can alert that can't
yet do the investigation to say what's
really occurring detecting an outbreak
is really just the first step there are
multiple other things that need to
happen ultimately we need to determine
what kinds of risks does this pose is it
likely to spread if it's going to spread
where might it go what kind of
consequences might occur from from that
spread and then ultimately we have to
get that information into the hands of
people who can then be empowered with
that information to take the appropriate
actions it's not just about tracking
though the dream is that one day a I
might be able to conjure up necessary
vaccines on the spot or repurpose drugs
to deal with new challenges
the latter being something benevolent AI
in London is already leading the way on
this company uses AI to better
understand the mechanism of disease
correlating data on illnesses drugs and
outcomes and providing more information
than any human being could ever come up
with and in this case a potential lead
what are we looking at here this is a
demonstration of our algorithm
processing documents in real time
reading the abstracts of scientific
publications to do with coronavirus and
extracting relationships between key
biological concepts that we really care
about to carry out drug discovery at
this point we're just a few months into
an outbreak that could really really
grow how meaningful do you think this
data is so far there's a huge amount of
information being published we're not
just putting our coronavirus information
but we're merging it with a lot of
existing publications on underlying
biology our algorithms reason over
biology at multiple layers from the nano
world of proteins interacting on
ourselves through this maze of
biological processes up to human defined
definitions of diseases
it's very early days for the process but
it is suggesting what might be worth
further investigation now a lot of
people were looking at virals antivirals
and how they went might potentially you
know treat the disease we looked at it
from a completely different way we said
what are the other types of approved
drugs that might inhibit the progression
of that disease in the body so we
surfaced a number of drugs and then we
did some experimentation based on that
and further research and then we came up
with this one drug that we think is best
suited it has both anti-inflammatory
properties as well as the ability to
stop what's called endocytosis which is
what enables the virus to enter the
lungs which is the most you know
potentially dangerous outcome of the
corona virus the company stresses this
is only conjecture and although the drug
in question is approved for use in
rheumatoid arthritis clinical trials and
full scientific evidence would be needed
before it could even come close to being
used for this purpose what we're trying
to do is use this technology in the
service of science to further the
development of novel treatments for
diseases that currently have no
treatment like right now in the world
there's over 9,000 diseases that have no
treatment okay I will play a greater
role than it has already because what's
being done is genetic sequences are
being taken that is the understanding of
the the organism itself and this is put
into databases that then can determine
where a virus came from where it might
be going in the future
of course AI hasn't sold the covet 19
crisis but it has hopefully helped to
some extent and should be learning from
it to be even more helpful in any future
disease outbreaks